ah this is a big story that happened
over the last I guess we would say 12 to
12 to 14 hours you probably know if you
watch our show that for weeks and weeks
and weeks the White House has been super
careful not to admit that Donald Trump
was in any way involved or even knew
about the hundred and thirty thousand
dollars in hush money that was paid and
the non-disclosure agreement that was
put in place for pornstar stormy Daniels
who had an affair with Donald Trump I
think at this point we can say with
basic basically total certitude that the
affair took place it's a question of how
much Trump was involved in the cover-up
and the framing all along from the Trump
side has been first of all it's all made
up now if you don't believe that it's
all made up and increasingly people
don't the argument is the payment was
made personally by Trump's personal
attorn attorney Michael Cohen the
non-disclosure agreement doesn't even
have Trump's signature on it which we
talked about yesterday is probably a way
to try to maintain plausible deniability
about the entire thing but the strategy
all along has been never acknowledged
that anything took place and certainly
don't acknowledge that Trump had any
knowledge of or involvement in any deal
making whatsoever with stormy Daniels
regardless of whether you believe that
the affair did or didn't take place it
all blew up in trumps face yesterday and
he is now reportedly furious with his
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
because she seemed to accidentally admit
at least it appeared to be an accident
that Donald Trump was involved in
arbitration with stormy Daniels and
presumably knew about that hush money
payment and a nondisclosure agreement in
in this apparent desperation to show
that Trump came out on top
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said we won this
in arbitration and of course any normal
person would say well if you're
admitting that there's something to win
it sorry if you're admitting that you
won something you're admitting that
there was something to win which has not
been directly acknowledged until
yesterday take a look at this first clip
breasts are feelings on that situation
regards to the ax stormy Daniels payment
but specifically can I ask did the
president approve of the payment that
was made in October 2016 by his longtime
lawyer and advisor Michael Cohen look
the president has addressed these
directly and made very well clear that
none of these allegations are true this
case has already been won in arbitration
and anything beyond that I would refer
you to the president's outcome outside
counsel when did the president address
specifically the cash payment it was
made in October of 2016 has denied the
allegations against him and again this
case has already been won and
arbitration anything beyond that I would
refer you to outside counsel about that
at this time though I've addressed this
as far as I can go yeah so listen number
one Jeff Zeleny is right that Trump
hasn't addressed this directly but let's
ignore that for now because twice there
Sarah Huckabee Sanders says we Trump won
this in arbitration and there was
follow-up because it didn't get by the
reporters in the room who realized if
something has been won then who won it
and when and in this next clip I
apologize because the sound on the
source clip glitches but I think we'll
still be able to figure out sort of the
gist of what Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
saying here I do have a question about
something you said earlier responsible
question you said that there's
arbitration that's already been won by
and win by the president's personal
attorneys and for details on that I
would refer you to them you're aware of
them so what can you more can you hear
with us I can share that counsel on any
details beyond that yellow that second
part is huge right Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is the White House press
secretary she doesn't report about
issues that relate only to Trump's
attorney Michael Cohen right in fact
she's super careful basically to never
explain anything to say anything that
doesn't relate directly to Donald Trump
she just says listen I'm the White House
press secretary and I can't speak about
that because it relates to this person
or that person who don't work in this
administration the fact that she says
something means that it relates to
Donald Trump and that Trump won
something in arbitration now
it's not true that Trump want anything
in arbitration by the way but that
doesn't matter because the big thing
here is if she even says that there was
something for Trump to win it's because
there is some agreement and totally
predictably Trump is furious Trump is
furious with Sarah Huckabee Sanders she
had been doing so well I guess compared
to Sean Spicer I don't know what the
what the frame of reference is and a
source said to CNN POTUS is very unhappy
Sarah gave the stormy Daniel storyline
steroids yesterday and then we got a
follow-up statement from stormy
Daniels's attorney who said yeah and he
won the popular vote to President Trump
hasn't won anything related to Miz
Clifford that stormy Daniels real name
first of all it doesn't appear as if he
was even a party to the arbitration miss
Sanders is referring to how can you win
something you're not even a part of
secondly claiming that mr. Trump won at
arbitration when there has been no
hearing no notice to miss Clifford no
opportunity to get given to her to
respond and no decision on the merits is
completely bogus not a good day for
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and clearly not a
good day for the narrative that Trump
has no idea it's all super confusing
where is this story coming from we don't
get it and I've said before that I find
Sarah Huckabee Sanders to be she
transmits this visceral feeling of
grandiosity about herself she really
seems to relish sort of exerting control
over the press corps during these
briefings and I for one am glad that she
has finally now slipped up and might
experience the wrath of an unhappy
Donald Trump yeah yesterday you were
talking about who in the White House is
likely to be the next to go
I didn't name her Sarah Huckabee Sanders
wasn't on that list know after this
gaffe I think you have to put her on
there things can to make a 180 very very
quickly with Trump you can get on
Trump's bad side in an instant and that
is what it appears that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders did so what will be next I mean
listen ultimately I think we all realize
that there's going to have to be some
accounting for or explanation of the
entire stormy Daniels thing my
prediction would be
that without ever admitting anything we
will get some kind of statement saying
yeah we paid her off because she was
lying at a time when it could have
affected the campaign and we wanted to
get her out of the way without ever
admitting anything although it becomes
more and more difficult to believe that
with every passing day send me your
thoughts on this story I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show we'll be back right
after this today's episode of the David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
brilliant which is a great online
service that allows you to master
concepts in math science and engineering
by solving fun and challenging problems
and unlike other learning sites when I'm
using brilliant I'm learning by working
hands-on with real-world scenarios and
problems you solve challenging puzzles
that have been designed by expert
educators and professionals from all
over the world they don't move too fast
they don't move too slowly they take you
step-by-step through the topics you're
interested in at your own pace and one
of their principles is effective
learning is active watching youtube
videos which is great by the way I
encourage it and I do it all the time
that's a more passive form of learning
that gets you so far
that's when brilliant comes in and
you're watching you're learning not by
watching but by actually doing and you
can get started right now at brilliant
org slash David Pakman first 200 to
visit the website brilliant org slash
David Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership but of course sign up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman